[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 25th of
august i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
what didn't the government tell us about
lockdown rishi sunako's public and an
exclusive interview for this week's
magazine saying the government stifled
debate about whether lockdown policies
worked or not fraser nelson who
interviewed rishi sunac will be on the
show
the effects of lockdown are still being
felt today in education the health
service and the economy michael simmons
will run us through the latest data
the revelations come as the tory
leadership contest enters its final
fortnight andrew neil and katie balls
will give us our political update
turning to china cindy you asked in a
column this week why either you're a
china hawk or a shill for beijing
there's no options in between she says
a new book second city looks at how
birmingham became so central to british
history but is the city overlooked i'll
speak to the author richard vinon and to
adrian woolridge
and finally should we laugh when someone
gets chased by cows john conley doesn't
think so he'll join me
a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today you'll pay just
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year to
subscribe today go to spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel click the red subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
bell icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
it was wrong to scare people like that
that's a quote from the new interview
with rishi sunak in this week's
spectator the former chancellor and now
leadership hopeful
has gone public on how the government
stifled criticism of lockdowns certain
officials he says were too powerful and
went too far fraser nelson the editor of
the spectators spoke to rishi sunak and
he joins me now fraser for this week's
magazine you spoke to rishi sunak former
chancellor of the extractor and now
leadership contender
he has decided to go on the record about
what really happened during lockdown
specifically what big decisions were and
weren't being made inside whitehall can
you tell us about it
yes and i've been hearing rumors for
quite a while that rishi sunak was
constantly the voice of opposition if
you like about lockdown not so much that
he was opposed to it but he was saying
look if you're going to close down the
schools then let's talk about what's
going to happen to the children who are
going to be at home you'd hear that he'd
get angry at meetings saying look um my
kids are at private school my wife can
take time off work look after her kids
what about the working class single
mother
who will absolutely not have those
options where are the models what's
going to happen to them um when i tried
to stand up the story when i was when he
was still chancellor i didn't get very
far he was quite clammed up so you'd
hear rumors that you could never confirm
it now now that he has quits governments
and he hasn't got much to lose certainly
his um his despair at boris johnson
isn't exactly a secret anymore so i
thought i i said to him look um why
don't you just go on the record and talk
about lockdown people need to know about
this and he very much agreed to be
honest i'm not quite sure why he didn't
do it earlier because what he had to say
i think is quite dramatic
and i think it's um it does demonstrate
but at least in that government there
was somebody who was trying to ask the
basic questions now
what really shocked me about the whole
interview
was that it was exactly as bad as we
suspected that even not just in the
cabinets but the quad the top four
people of government they weren't asking
questions really about what the
long-term health impacts were going to
be what was the cancer impact what would
it do to the nhs waiting list what would
it do to the economy and and there was a
policy russia synagogue says that you
weren't even allowed to talk about this
as a minister you were given these these
lines to take the script as he calls it
and the script was that you were not
allowed to acknowledge that any
drawbacks to to lockdown and he said he
was appalled to find that rather than
level with the public and be honest
about the gamble that was being taken
that instead they got this fear
messaging was relentless these posters
saying you know look him in the eyes and
tell him you'll never flout the rules
and these fear posters rasheed like said
were opposed by him obvious by his team
in the treasury because he felt they
would do really bad damage to the
national psyche there were surveys he
was saying showing that britain was
least likely of all countries in europe
to bounce back from recession because if
you hammer this message of fear to the
public you can expect long-term
ramifications and lo and behold that's
what happened britain ended up with the
worst economic damage in the whole of
europe so it was a pretty um
depressing um experience hearing that
the quality of decision-making in
government was exactly as bad as we had
feared
there are a lot of new pieces of
information
in this piece the cover piece for the
magazine this week i would encourage all
spectator tv watchers to
read it um two things in particular
really jumped out to me when i read
through your piece phraser the first is
the moment where rishi sunek is having
one of these meetings and he finally
decides that it's time to talk about
education now he of course is not the
education secretary he's the finance guy
but he brings it up and he's met with
silence because nobody else wants to
talk about what's happening to children
while they're home not getting proper
schooling the second thing that i
thought was very interesting is that he
had a treasury mole on a lot of these
sage phone calls and meetings that they
didn't realize was there for a long time
so he was getting some feedback from the
meetings where they would discuss things
which actually turned out to very often
be different from the reports that
cabinet ministers would get and broadly
speaking it was not being reported to
politicians that there actually was
dissent and there was disagreement in a
lot of these meetings it was
intentionally designed to make
politicians and certainly the public
think that there was complete consensus
on lockdowns and how severe they had to
be and how long they had to be but it
really wasn't the case so i was
wondering if you could speak to to both
of those things
well well the first point of education i
mean the shocking thing he was saying
was it was the first time that anybody
had really made that point you think it
was an emotional point it wasn't a
policy one he was saying surely those of
us around this table can agree that
denying classroom education to kids is a
bad thing that will harm them and he
says that you wouldn't even get
agreement on that point because such was
the culture created in number 10 that to
speak rationally about um lockdown
having bad effects as well as
potentially good ones that was a heresy
if you were to speak if you to use your
mind and try to ask natural probing
questions about what happens when you
close on society at that stage it had
become seen as an attack on boris
johnson personally now rasheed sunuk
said it was time after time he was the
only person in the cabinet making these
points and pretty soon he became
suspected of number 10 of basically
doing this for political maneuvering of
trying to position himself as the next
prime minister perhaps that's where the
um rushi boris tension originated in
those locktown discussions
now also sage i found this personally
one of the most interesting points of it
we all know that when we were locked
down it was on the same format these
scientists were paraded with the um as
basically being our our real government
now rishi sanek was saying that
they decided rather than to present
lockdown as a political decision which
it was to present it as following the
science now of course if you say you're
following the science then you're more
protected from scrutiny but in order to
get away with that you needed to elevate
sage which it was only ever set up as a
sprawling committee of various advisors
into some kind of mini lockdown
government who would go away and come up
with memos and those memos would be sent
to the cabinet meeting and that all of a
sudden would be what they had to do
because they wanted to follow the
science then they had to do whatever
stage said so you had a complete
collapse a complete collapse and
democratic responsibility there was no
accountability in parliament because
boris johnson had used emergency powers
to do whatever he wanted there was no
discussion in cabinet because the
cabinets were given instructions they
weren't let in on it
and even when it came to again the top
the very top people in government
including the chancellor of yeast
checker he said that he was asking over
time how did sage come to this
recommendation what are the assumptions
behind this model what happens if those
assumptions are wrong this picture might
not look as as dreary
if you change the assumptions and he was
saying that even he as chancellor of the
exchequer wasn't told what assumptions
were used to complete these sage models
upon which the country was locked down
now
this is as he says
this is just sheer incompetence if
you're going to make any decision in
public health you do a cost cost benefit
analysis what's sometimes called a
quality analysis a quality of life years
analysis if you're going to um change
the regulation on junk food and
advertising on cancer screening you
would do a cost benefit analysis but at
no point richie snack says at no point
was this analysis ever done for lockdown
the most dramatic the most draconian
principle ever introduced in post-war
british government so the lives of
millions of people the livelihoods of
people the children's education and a
whole bunch of other things from whether
you can visit your relatives to whether
you could attend your parents funeral
all of these were decided and policies
are being rushed through with nothing
resembling the sort of scrutiny that you
would require and we only know this
because russia sunk has not come out and
said it fraser let's look into those
sage graphs a little bit more and the
assumptions behind them because
something i found really interesting in
the piece was that rishi sunak was
suggesting if these kinds of graphs
landed on my desk about anything related
to his remit about the economy about
finance
he would not have accepted them the
assumptions behind them were not good
enough or even clear or even stated
they were essentially in many cases he
felt half-baked and if they landed on
his desk for another reason he would
have just said throw him out start again
and i remember at the time there was a
real culture building up in the uk that
to question these sage graphs was
essentially to question fact and it was
very nerve-wracking to do sometimes and
in fact i think one of the major reasons
that the spectator created its data hub
was to give the public access to these
graphs just the straight numbers so that
the data in almost real time could be
available at their fingertips because we
didn't think that was being made
available or put forward by what was
happening in government and dare i say
some of us had a suspicion that these
numbers weren't being crunched properly
but again it was very scary at points to
suggest that because of the names that
might come your way
it feels like rishi sunak is only
validating uh the fact that you know
these these graphs really weren't up to
scratch and and he certainly didn't feel
uh like this was the best kind of
analysis that could be landing on his
desk
yeah and as russian says that by the
time the fourth lockdown came along it
didn't happen by the way that was last
december by then he had eventually
managed to put a team around him he
managed to hire some modelers because
previously he lost all the treasury
modelers to the office for budget
responsibility so he had the apparatus
he needed to sense check the sage
analysis when it came in last december
now because exactly the same
maneuverings were taking place he was
saying there was they were all set to
call a press conference and then that
announced a lockdown so he flew back
from california and pretty much
threatened to resign and said to boris
johnson look you've got to have a
cabinet meeting because if you do then
you then the cabinet will all virtually
to a man apart from michael gove and
sachin javid then health secretary
the rest of them will be anti-lockdown
and they'll give you the political cover
that you need now when that happened we
saw for the first time
how sage predictions compared to reality
so once the sage memo which cabinet
members were sent last december said
that the um the deaths could be up to
six thousand a day that was the the
upper bounds of limits given to them and
in the end i think that was out by a
factor of 20. but russia synagogue knew
this because jp morgan an investment
bank had done his own analysis based on
real-world south african data and said
actually if you look at the south
african trajectory it means that britain
can carry this without lockdown so let's
consider this again the livelihoods and
lives of millions of people were on the
line last december the official advice
being given to ministers gave them
something like and like 14 different
scenarios all of which were bleaker than
what actually turned out to be the case
but the jp morgan analysis from a bunch
of bankers have got no real professional
interest in modeling lockdown that was
accurate so ministers were being spun
they were being spun with graphs which
rasheed sinek says they were unable to
challenge
and who knows how much unnecessary
damage was done because let's remember
in the um in the february of 2020 after
the vaccine of 2021 when the vaccine had
come along there was a big decision
taken to keep us all on lockdown right
up until july that was a devastating
news for those who thought the vaccines
might translate into being able to
liberalize the economy and that decision
was taken because of sage modelling
rishi sununu has now confirmed what we
all suspected for that sage modeling was
not something that could be properly
tested by government and his in his
suspicion it was probably wrong and it
didn't pass anything like the scrutiny
or the robustness or the kind of the
basic kind of critical questioning that
you would need to make any public health
intervention letting la let alone
closing down or locking down a country
fraser critics will question the timing
of rishi sunax intervention here
they'll point to the leadership campaign
they'll say that this is a very
convenient moment for him to put out his
version of events to paint himself as
the anti-lockdown minister or at least
the one who was questioning lockdown
when he suggests everybody else was
relatively relaxed about the prolonged
infringement of on our civil liberties
do you believe rishi sunac's version of
events are they credible to you do they
stack up
and they are credible to me because the
squares of what had been told at the
time
i also was a recipient of a hostile
number 10 briefing against rishi sunek
where i was told by one of boris
johnson's aides that here was this
chancellor he was against the lockdown
he was basically you know
effectively more relaxed about people
dying of covert pretty hostile briefing
so this does square
with and also um there are other
anecdotes moving around also this wasn't
his idea it wasn't the brainwave of the
snake campaign to talk about lockdown
this was something that i've been trying
to push him to do for quite some time
basically saying that he had nothing to
lose now from telling the complete truth
but when he was in lockdown of course he
couldn't go on so when he was in
government of course he couldn't say
that boris johnson was responsible for
all his bad decisions you can't do that
without resigning but when he had
resigned he didn't want to talk about
his role in lockdown but i thought this
was a very rare
moment where during the campaign where
he was still in the mood for giving
interviews he might not be if he loses
this contest and goes into sort of
semi-political retirement that we could
it was a good chance to get him on the
record and to get him to speak freely oh
my gosh he spoke freely
and i suppose nuances are important here
when i read your write-up i didn't come
away thinking that rishi sunuk was
actually anti-lockdown i came away
thinking that he was frustrated that
there was no discussion of trade-offs
through that almost two-year process
yes i mean at the end of it i said to
him two things first of all public
opinion was so strongly for m lockdown
something like 70 percent could any
prime minister really have stood up to
that level of public demand and he was
saying well look public opinion was
shaped partly by the government's fear
messaging and also it was never
explained to people that there was pros
and cons to lock down if they thought
the lockdown might deprive their kids of
education they might never get back it
might lead to an ahs backlog and it
might lead to
greater excess deaths from cancer and
what have you and then there might not
have been so much in favor of it um but
but also you know fundamentally he
didn't have much to
re there wasn't much of an agenda here
for him of course he thinks he'll think
to himself as probably help him with the
tory party members who broadly speaking
were anti-lockdown but if he was going
to make this a core part of his campaign
he would have done it from day one we're
right now in the last week of the
campaign probably the majority of tory
party members have cast their vote so i
don't think this revolution is going to
help him really inventory leadership
race but those but for those of us
trying to piece together what's happened
in lockdown and trying to work out if it
really was as bad as we suspected this
interview certainly puts on the record
lots of things which i think um people
need to know about all of our lives were
affected by this and i think that the
the sheer lack of scrutiny lack of
thought lack of testing lack of
discussion in the government is
something that deserves to be put on the
public record
fraser thanks for joining me
the pandemic might be over but the
effects of lockdown are still being felt
exam results have been skewed hospital
figures are awful and the economy is in
a bad state to explain what's behind the
data i'm joined now by the spectator's
data journalist michael simmons
michael thanks for joining me on
spectator tv with this summer's exam
results in mess and with the nhs waiting
list growing ever more dire the effects
of lockdown are becoming clearer let's
start with education can you run us
through what happened with this year's
results and how lockdown had an effect
on that
yep so this year's exam results were
interesting because as i'm sure everyone
will know this is the first year that we
went back to kind of normal exam
conditions over the past two years of
lockdowns and the pandemic we had a
variety of systems involving algorithms
and teacher assessed grades but this
year was the first year that um exams
were effectively back to normal and the
department of education had actually
decided that grade inflation and as
we've written about in the spectator um
has been a big problem you know and
last year i think something like 20 of a
level students were getting you know the
top highest grades which is just the
system is kind of not designed for that
and so this year they decided that they
wanted to get the kind of grade results
sort of closer to normal and what's
happened in the results that came out
last week was that the um the grades
were
lower than they had been during teacher
assessment years but they're still
inflated kind of on pre-pandemic and
kind of what the results issue really
show us is the the effects that that
great inflation and kind of who
benefited because we've seen
different trends go back to normal so
for instance um kids in private schools
seem to do better when there was teacher
assessed grades girls tend to do better
when there's teacher assessed grades and
so now it's gone back to exams when
those numbers have gone down a bit is
kind of more evidence to the picture
that yes this was kind of all caused by
lockdown and one really interesting
example recently is there's a
been a study about the gcse results that
suggested that basically there's always
been this gender gap um and it was
thought that that gender gap got worse
during the lockdown years because
basically girls were more likely to
actually study while boys were all on
their playstations and this is something
that kind of doesn't happen in if you
haven't or happens to lesser extent if
you have a normal exam system
now that we're back to
assessing grades in the pre-pandemic way
is this eventually going to work itself
out and that's not meant to overlook the
huge upset that this is causing
kids and causing these students as they
try to make their grades for university
but do we consider this to be a
relatively short-term issue or will have
lockdown changed this and created
problems for the longer term as well
well it's it's kind of a difficult one
to answer because grade inflation
certainly at a level was kind of a
long-term trend anyway
and but it was kind of just like a small
inflation every year and then the
pandemic years just absolutely inflated
that like you know a kind of
gentle slope turned into like a vertical
line
and and so it's going to be certain like
difficult as they balance it out and the
government is going to have to decide
what they want to do about grade
boundaries but i think
kind of longer term and the questions
that lockdown has posed about
inequalities with how exams and
education is administered you can't just
go back to normal now that kind of this
information has been highlighted and so
i don't think things will go back to
normal over the long term but not for
any sort of natural reason but because
the government is probably going to
choose not to go back to normal
meanwhile we have new figures for nhs
waiting times that were released
recently with nearly 30 000 people
waiting more than 12 hours to get into a
e just last month this is the worst ever
uh number recorded how has it gotten so
bad
well i think this is a question that
even the nhs themselves are kind of
struggling to answer because there's
there's the obvious part which is that
people missed appointments in the
pandemic and now there's just this huge
backlog and
of people you know on waiting lists for
treatment
but why things are particularly acute in
a e and ambulance services and you know
the height of summer is kind of really
puzzling people
but one aspect that the nhs are now kind
of looking at as the kind of probable
cause is bed blocking that we've kind of
all been talking about for years has
kind of got really big during the
pandemic because after you know in the
first year of the pandemic when there
was all the
cases of people being moved to care
homes and did that cause care home
outbreaks that's kind of stopped now and
it's harder to get into care homes so
there's just huge amount of bed blocking
the nhs which you know balances down
between like from ward toward forward to
a e department and so people who just
cannot get into the any departments
cannot see their doctors and can't even
get an ambulance
and i imagine this has a knock on effect
so people are waiting in the ambulance
they can't get into a bed in hospital
and then people at home are waiting for
the ambulance which can't come to them
because they're still taking care of
somebody who isn't being admitted yet
well exactly and the the near 30
thousand figure that you highlighted for
people that are waiting 12 hours that's
and people that are waiting 12 hours you
know once they actually get into the a e
department that doesn't necessarily take
into account of people that are you know
waiting up to in some cases 10 hours in
an ambulance before they actually even
get through the doors of the emergency
department
wow that's terrifying stuff uh something
else really frightening out this week um
is the new very grim data around excess
death speakers in the uk can you talk us
through them yeah so excess deaths have
kind of been rumbling along this year
that they seemed kind of higher than
normal and you know a few people were
kind of worried about it but
and kind of it was kind of a below the
radar story but in recent weeks it's
just really um kind of uh it's really
exaggerated and you know come to the
forum we found that in 15 weeks of this
year the average for england and wales
has been about a thousand extra deaths
you know the last week of um data there
was over a thousand deaths as well and
what's really worrying doctors is that
because unfortunately you know during
the pandemic it tended to be the older
and vulnerable people who were killed
you know they were you were 70 times
more likely to die of covid if you were
older than if you were younger that
would kind of suggest that oh shouldn't
now that covets in a sense behind us
should we have less deaths but the
opposite is true and that's really
concerning people and there we now have
some data on some of the causes for that
and it looks to be um mainly
heart conditions and also diabetes so
you know that uh poses all its own
questions
michael thanks for joining me
we're entering the final fortnight of
the leadership contest liz trust looks
very likely to win but there's still a
couple more hustings left what should we
expect in these final few days and
what's trus's plan for government i'm
joined now by the spectators chairman
andrew neal and by our deputy political
editor katie balls
andrew and katie thanks for joining me
now andrew in this week's politics
column katie writes about the many
problems that are going to face probably
liz truss
who's most likely to enter downing
street in two weeks time the new prime
minister won't be able to get anything
done she writes unless she brings the
party together now do you think it's
possible andrew to create that kind of
unity right now given the current makeup
of mps and how they feel about liz truss
in particular
well it's a good question and katie's
column is uh is a must read on this
subject because it shows i mean in some
ways
rishi sunak who is almost certainly
going to lose they should be thinking
this is a good election to lose because
the inheritance of the new incumbent of
number 10 probably we think on september
6 she becomes prime minister for this
trust
is going to be terrible and we i'm sure
we'll come on to some of that economic
adherence inheritance in a minute the
thing that katie points out too is the
political inheritance i mean this is now
an unreally conservative party it's got
rebellion in its blood now it's divided
by north and south and tops and blue red
wall
tories that she doesn't command
widespread support uh in on the back
benches either and i think when you when
when the going gets tough then
conservative mps
prefer to squabble among each other and
i think she could well face lots of
rebellions now you could take the view
there's an election coming maybe still
be two years away but it's on its way
they've had enough of rebellion and it's
time to buckle down and behave more like
a governing united party
but i don't detect that i mean i think
this trust will be regarded as quite a
weak prime minister in the first place
and my guess would be that these
rebellious stories will continue to
cause trouble and make life difficult at
a difficult economic time they'll add to
that by making it politically difficult
for a prime minister to govern as well
katie what's liz truss's best bet for
reuniting her party you report in your
column this week that the government in
waiting is being assembled at evening
the foreign secretary's grace and favor
home will they be taking a balanced
approach looking at the next government
with reunification in mind or do you
think this is going to be more focused
on who was loyal to liz uh in terms of
who gets those top jobs
so i think there's a general hope of
course to unite the party because as uh
we have just uh you know heard from
andrew you you need to do that really to
have a functioning government that just
isn't dominated in terms of day-to-day
business on multiple rebellions um but
you've also have a campaign where uh i
think it is no great secret that liz
trust appears to have promised quite a
lot of people jobs and throughout this
rishi scenic i said i'm not going to
promise jobs um but there's been fairly
uh you know lots of conversations uh for
example i think there is a sense that
the fact that suella braveman seems
pretty nailed on for home secretary
under liz trust is because uh in the
second round uh when she was knocked out
she told her brexiteer backers to get
behind this trust and an agreement was
made that that is what lots of people
think happened of course it is not
confirmed and therefore in terms of the
cabinet roles i think the vast majority
of those are going to go to people who
have come out for liz trust whether
that's early or later on in the campaign
and i think there is more space
in terms of
those who bat racist unique in the
junior ministerial ranks but speaking to
those quite close to liz trust i think
there is a line that they think has been
crossed by some which is how how
aggressive have you been in this
campaign have you gone out on the attack
on the morning round have you sent
tweets suggesting uh that liz truster's
plans don't add up and that could mean
that you were you know left on the side
benches i think if we're looking at what
could actually
unite the party from speaking to lots of
figures for this column i think the the
one i just wondered perhaps uh could
come through is perhaps everyone's just
so tired mps want this leadership
contest to be over
they've wanted it to be over you know
several weeks ago and therefore there
isn't much appetite to go through this
all the go all again in the next you
know in the next year so that might mean
there's a little bit less bloodletting
but i think that is um probably a hope
rather than certain
i think the other thing to take into
account is that as always happens at
this
in the lifetime of a parliament is that
the tory back benches are going to be
packed with uh rather angry
disillusioned dispossessed big beasts
all well-known names to the media all
newsmaker names rishi sunak almost
certainly i mean if
uh bravoman is going to be the new home
secretary is pretty patel going to be on
the back benches
after this perhaps dominic rabb will be
on the back benches and someone else
will be on the back benches and that's
somebody called boris johnson who is the
biggest newsmaker of them all so there's
plenty of scope for um mischief for
criticism for big news because it's
always for us as journalists there's
always bigger news when you're being
attacked by your own side i mean it's
labor's job to attack the tories it
isn't necessarily blue on blue uh to to
do that but i was looking back if you
look at um
margaret thatcher stepped down john
major lost the election david cameron
stepped down and then theresa may
stepped down not one of these outgoing
prime ministers ever had a chance or i
believe ever wanted to come back as
prime minister
but when i see what's coming out of the
johnson camp at the moment there's all
sorts of indications that he's uh you
know it's not just asta la vista as he
said it's i'll be back you know there's
a sense that he still thinks he'll be
vindicated it'll be a complete disaster
this winter and he may well be back and
he will not be able to stop himself i
mean publicity to boris johnson is like
oxygen to the rest of us he needs it to
keep alive
and and he will quickly find out if the
moment he just says something like
it could be rainy tomorrow
that will be front page news and he'll
say hey look at all the publicity i've
just got and he will not be able to stop
himself from doing it and that will make
life very difficult for liz trusts as
prime minister and yet andrew there is a
risk here that the public become very
tired of tory infighting and tory drama
with the cost of living crisis they have
their own problems to worry about let
alone the problems in the tory party do
you think the party is soon going to be
punished for this sense of ongoing drama
well the public don't like parties that
are divided in the particularly
governing parties and they don't like
parties that squabble among themselves
but i think that's true with knobs on
when you're in the middle of an economic
tsunami as we will be by the autumn of
this year i mean i don't believe the
citibank uh forecast the inflation will
hit 18
but we know that it's going to be high
and it's going to be very painful and
that cost of living uh crisis is going
to get worse the recession is beckoning
and certainly a major slowdown that will
be true in europe and improv
probably in america as well it's already
happened in america by the technical
definition these will be green grim
economic times there are a whole slew of
um
of
how can i go to transport disruption
going on through strikes let's trust as
a leader who's no experience of dealing
with labor issues at all
so if at a time of what you might call
national crisis and i see one cabinet
minister i think it was quasi quote has
talked of that we are in a national
economic emergency i think that is the
one time above all when the british
people will not expect this governing
party to be knocking lumps out of each
other so okay i think it's very
dangerous for the tories and katie on
that point i mean from your perspective
how does the party hang on for at least
two more years and going into a general
election make the case when such
difficult economic times they're not
just here i mean they have arrived but
many people think this is the beginning
that it's only going to get worse
well i think it's an interesting
question which is when would liz trust
uh decide to call for an election and
as ever people saying oh could you go
for an early election given uh the next
few years are going to be so grim
perhaps she'll get a you know honeymoon
perhaps you'll get bounce
for example labor i mean private
documents but you get the sense they
might want them out there as suggesting
they think she'll get a big bounce that
to me seems quite tricky it may not
happen just given how difficult things
are for most people at the moment
and the fact that lots of people don't
really think now is the time for a tory
leadership contest but say she does get
you know up go up a bit in the polls the
tories perhaps edged back over labor in
that scenario i still don't think she
really go for an early election because
what effect really is the message to
voters what we have a majority in the
region of 80 i think 71 at the last
count um but we want to go for a
probably a smaller majority in an
election and then we'll be able to deal
with the cost of living in a more
thorough way it doesn't really work in
terms of a message
and therefore actually will she try and
push this back as far as possible i
think the best hope for the
conservatives is they just but you know
whether this storm and things start to
improve inflation starts to you know
look as though it's going down before
the next election and but given how
tricky it is to navigate and some of the
obviously the potential risks of liz
trust's economic plans in terms of the
potential effect on inflation that could
be very hard to do
andrew when we go into the next election
whether it's next year the year after
we're looking at 13 14 years of a tory
government sometimes in coalition
sometimes not but the tories have
have been steering the ship
is there any way to look at this now
apart from essentially managed decline
that
there has to be
a reset at some point the other side has
to get in at some point and with things
looking as bleak as they are about to be
we just have to interpret all this is is
how you manage that decline whether and
rather than you know can you avoid the
decline
well i agree with katie that i don't
think the the a trust administration
will be in no position to call the rally
election uh there's this cost of living
crisis isn't going away quickly she's
going to make a ton of mistakes as an
incomer as a novice uh our television
performances are going to be a matter of
uh national interest that we put it
politely
that way uh so i think it's
i would guess the earlier she would have
an election would be in the spring or
early summer of 2024
which is a little less than two years
away
if of course she gets her act together
then there is still all to play for if
she really does know what she's doing if
she really does have a plan for growth
the current period that we are in could
be very different i mean the cost of
living crisis could be over uh inflation
could have come but by 2024 inflation
will be backed down not to the bank of
england's 2 target but i suspect it will
be under 5 maybe even under 4
wages will be strong because the liberal
market will be
tight and maybe she will have thought of
a number of things
to do that are popular so i wouldn't
rule it out but as we sit here at the
moment
as we move into the autumn of 2022
you would have to say that the tories
have an uphill struggle to keep on to
power they don't seem to know what to do
with that power anymore they don't
really have a vision or a mission or a
set of really important policies other
than very vague ones about tax cuts they
have no idea how to get a hold of
government spending and kyo stamber bit
by bit
undemonstrably not with massive cut
through but bit by bit he's getting his
party back on track and making it a
party that
very different from
uh michael foote way back in 83 even
neil kinnick in 87 or jeremy corbyn in
uh
2017 and 2019
people aren't going to be frightened by
kirsten they may not want to live with
government they may not want mr starmer
as prime minister but it ain't going to
frighten the horses the way these
previous liver leaders did and so i
think if he just keeps his head down
keeps plodding
and there may even be a sense
that people would want a period of quiet
under undemonstrative rather dull labor
government
compared to the
endless fireworks under the
conservatives
andrew and katie thanks for joining me
turning now to china the spectator cindy
in her column this week argues that you
can either be a china hawk or you're a
shill for china she increasingly feels
like there's no in between she joins me
now
cindy in your column for the magazine
this week you talk about the s word what
is that word
so the s word is the word show
and i talk in my column about how much i
dislike it um now that's not because
there are no shells in in the uk are
planted by foreign states like china
there are of course there are i mean
only earlier this year mi5 warned about
christine lee uh giving barry gardner
hundreds of thousands of pounds um not
sure why barry gardner um because it
clearly she wasn't that good of her
anyway whatever so clearly these real
shows exist but what i have a problem
with is when people um accuse certain
people in the china world or whatever it
is of being shows just because what they
say what their analysis is based on
their experience or their
knowledge about china for example
doesn't fit with a certain world view
and in the china policy world we're
seeing this increasing uh black and
whiteness coming on where you're either
a china hawk in which case you believe
in cutting off diplomatic relations you
believe in declaring genocide or if
you're falling anywhere short of that
then you're shilling for china and
there's a word i've heard many times
occasionally it's applied to me
never to my face or often in comment
sections or you know i hear friends of
people talking to my friends about that
but also to other organizations and
other experts who you know are much more
established have a lot to say of a lot
of value to offer this critical moment
of our relations with china but are just
being written off because what they're
saying doesn't fit with the extreme
hawkish world view and that's really
what i'm railing against
you talk a bit about your personal
experience in your piece for the
magazine and you say that in the past
you recognized it as objectively good
banter with people that you knew and
trusted to have jokes around this idea
of being a shell but that it's becoming
less and less funny because you feel
like it's an accusation that is actually
levied at you from time to time and one
that you find quite offensive
yeah i mean for the reasons that i've
explained you know i think fundamentally
it is a funny joke uh and you know when
i when i know people don't mean it
seriously you know it's funny to go
along with it i mean just look at me you
know
listeners and viewers will hear my
suspiciously posh accent even though i
wasn't even born in this country i
couldn't speak english until the age of
10
where did this accent come from um
people will point to the fact that i was
born and bred in china my first language
is mandarin which i still speak uh and
read um as well as the fact that i work
in the heart of of westminster now um so
what better place for the ccp to play
some kind of spy right and that's a
really funny joke to go along with but
when it's actually uh as i say pushing
out uh people with expertise and i don't
i don't necessarily count myself and now
i just me you know one example i give is
the great britain china center
now kate this is an arms-length body of
the foreign office set up in 1974 so not
a golden era legacy from the david
cameron george osborne years but its
work basically included uh promoting and
supporting liberal minds within china
and helping them get legal reform and
criminal justice reform a very laudable
goal as well as in westminster training
mps and civil servants up on their china
101 basically answering questions like
who's in charge in china who's in charge
in the chinese communist party
what does beijing want his team down you
know all these very vital questions that
even china hawks need to have answers to
this center gave those answers in a very
um extensive way it got different
experts in but let's trust in one of her
final acts as foreign secretary has
actually axed uh the funding for the
center so it doesn't it now looks set to
close and it was only asking for about
500 000 pounds a year which is you know
surely peanuts in her mind these days
which are only operating billions of
pounds these days um and the reason for
that i hear from those close to her is
because she sees it as a china shill
organization and the reason she sees it
as that is because it sometimes hosts
ccp officials like the chinese
ambassador to the uk now kate i realize
i'm going on but last i checked we still
have diplomatic relations with china and
if anything it's very valuable for our
mps to be able to speak to you and
challenge their ccp counterparts because
otherwise access is incredibly hard
especially at this moment where it
doesn't look like uh we're going into a
very tense moment with china so to act
the funding of a center like this which
hasn't been funded by the chinese it has
been funded by the british and has
always worked within the realms of
british foreign policy just seems to me
so short-sighted um and i quote
professor rana mitta from oxford
university um probably uk's um most
eminent china expert where he says you
know we've gone in this country from the
golden era to now we've gone from
complacency to panic without the
intervening stage of knowledge and you
know fundamentally i think that sums up
the entire problem
you make some good cold war comparisons
in your piece noting that the expertise
in the uk around russia back then it was
arguably very good and something that we
just don't have today in the uk when it
comes to china but i suppose the counter
to your case for the great britain china
center is that perhaps that isn't where
you develop
those skill sets and those people and
that knowledge
is a taxpayer-funded quasi-public
academic body really the place to
achieve this i mean surely this is an
issue that's better for the foreign
office and for our intelligence service
to really be beefing up their
recruitment
and improving the skill set and the
knowledge within those bodies to make
sure that that we are able to have this
dialogue when it's appropriate but
frankly more aggressive discussions when
it's appropriate absolutely i mean i i
think i don't see it as either all which
is the assumption of your question i
think if we could have all of those
things that would be fantastic and here
i sound like liz trust as well but
fundamentally the situation in our
foreign office yes cindy where are your
spending caps
fundamental on china i am caicos i
believe in having all of the expertise
we possibly could have and i believe in
having more funding for it um when we
look at the status quo in our
establishment at the moment it's
incredibly dire so this magazine steer
pipe columnist uh found recently that
there were only 41 diplomats in the
foreign office who speak mandarin that's
less than the amount of people who speak
russian even now and certainly much much
less than the people amount of people
who spoke russian during the peak of the
cold war and there's just not enough
expertise there uh secret services
recently uh basically admitted this
problem and have gone on a recruitment
drive the results of which i hope we'll
be seeing in the coming years but when
you look at academia when you're looking
at schools you know mandarin is very
rarely offered in our schools we're
still taught about the tudors and the
nazis again and again and again and you
can go through our entire school career
without learning about
the rest of the world let alone about
china
and also when you're looking at
universities a shocking statistic is
that actually there are only 300
graduates of chinese language each year
in the uk and that's a number that
hasn't increased since 1999 which was
before china joined the wto so we are in
a completely different world now but the
british education system and the british
establishment hasn't woken up to that
yet
and i guess what i'm saying is that fine
let's be hawkish all you want but let's
have expertise behind that there's no
way it's going to hurt the ccp if you
really want to do that
because you can't just go around
stabbing in the dark which unfortunately
i think is what we're doing at the
moment
do you think the us and other countries
are better prepared to have the
difficult conversations around china
than the uk i mean these conversations
are certainly growing in the us but do
you think that
the expertise and the resources in say
the united states are going to better
equip them than what we have here in the
uk i think i think that is true um there
are many more china experts in the u.s
for the u.s government china is much
more of a deliberate policy than the
kind of ad hoc uh issue by issue thing
we're seeing in the uk and partly that's
to do with history i mean if you bear in
mind the fact that before china was
communist the nationalist party had very
close links with the american government
and that's why america has such close
links to taiwan these days um and that's
a refreshment that's a historical link
uh direct bilateral relations that has
continued um after a brief brief break
but that has continued with modern china
as well the uk hasn't ever had that kind
of direct bilateral relationship and you
know i mean what little shared history
china and the uk have have often been
tainted by brutality if you think about
the opium wars so i think
we are catching up here um and we can
get more help from the us and certainly
in my podcast for the spectator chinese
whispers i often have american guests on
more than british guests just because
there's many more people there talking
about china um but you know we can catch
up and i think we must because our
approach to china has to be different to
the u.s approach because we are not the
us and so in order to do that let's um
basically to use the jargon off the
foreign office build our china
capability uh and to start doing that by
not writing off experts as shows
cindy thanks for joining me
a new book second city looks at
birmingham's role in british history it
doesn't always get the fairest hearing
says its author richard vinnin
why richard joins me now alongside
adrian woolridge global business
columnist at bloomberg
adrian richard thanks so much for
joining spectator tv
to start richard your book second city
is all about how birmingham became so
central to britain's history why is the
city so often overlooked
um
i think a variety of reasons i think
partly because it's a very unglamorous
city so it's kind of the city of
crossroads
it's not especially in recent years a
very physically attractive city
uh i suppose it's close to london so i
mean i used to live in houston in texas
and it struck me in houston in texas you
can drive for 90 miles and not leave the
city limits and if you drive for 90
limits in birmingham you'd be in
trafalgar square so it sort of feels
like it doesn't have the kind of
separate identity in some ways that a
northern city might have so i think
those are some of the reasons um i think
it also doesn't
it doesn't quite fit people's kind of
expectations of what
a provincial city or a working-class
city ought to be
um so especially in the post-war period
it seems to me that you know
the provinces have a kind of
um
cult
but it's a cult that revolves around
them behaving themselves behaving like a
provincial city ought to behave
and especially during this great kind of
boom from the late 30s to the mid 70s
when birmingham has very full employment
it's always a bit kind of brassy and
over self-confident and i think that
kind of means it's not what people want
you know working class
you know non-london place to be so
priestly jb priestly writes about
birmingham writes this book english
journey in the early 30s and he has a
wonderful phrase about birmingham he
says it has the wrong kind of vulgarity
very disapproving and i think lots of
people think that birmingham has the
wrong kind of vulgarity adrian you very
recently wrote a column for bloomberg
saying that birmingham was on the up do
you think the city however is still
underappreciated
oh it's very much underappreciated but
there are people who are beginning to
re-up birmingham um i think the i wrote
the column just when we were about to
have the commonwealth games which puts a
certain amount of focus on it there's
obviously the tv series peaky blinders
which has given us a sort of gangster
glamour
the right sort of glamour in some ways
to attract the attention of hollywood
and places like that and i think it's
also a very interesting city from a
political point of view i mean nick
timothy was a person who focused very
much on birmingham with the notion of
erdington man and his cult of joe
chamberlain he said that this is the
sort of city that we need for the future
of conservatives because conservatism
needs to find a way of addressing people
outside london uh addressing the sort of
the manufacturing sector of the economy
with a rebalancing of the economy
towards the manufacturing industry and
addressing sort of ordinary people um
the great mass middle of uh of britain
and although the nick timothy products
sort of imploded in many ways i think it
was the the first signs of a re
reorientation of the conservative party
towards
towards ordinary britain and i think
we'll
you know the fate of birmingham and the
fate of the uh conservative party and
its attempt to to address
you know they talk a lot about
addressing the north but a lot of it is
about addressing middle provincial
england outside just outside the the the
the obvious northern belt with its
peculiar identities so i think
birmingham really matters at the moment
politically and and you know and as with
peaky blind as culturally
and adrian tell us a bit more about
joseph chamberlain uh he's a big part of
your column once the mayor of birmingham
he transformed the city uh you say in
your piece
yeah well joseph chamberlain was um you
know the in many ways the creator of a
new sort of conservatives and he starts
off as a liberal but he moves eventually
to to the right and it's a new sort of
conservatism which is based on the
manufacturing sector based on industry
and based on the notion of civic
capitalism the idea that you need to
have great provincial cities
great provincial manufacturers a duty of
the business class to root itself in its
localities and to do its best by by its
workers and i think that that sort of
thing again so central to nick timothy's
vision of the future of conservatives
and it's it's sort of slightly um
declined uh recently but i think it has
a big future if you look at what's
happening to american conservatism again
you're seeing the republican party
trying to turn itself into a
manufacturing uh into um a sort of a
manufacturing uh party a party of the
working class um and talking about you
know civic conservatives and
particularly in in you know with marco
rubio and things like that so i think
that you know on the broader scale of
things despite recent setbacks of that
uh project in
in in britain um it it will you know
it's still got a long way to go so
joseph chamberlain is a figure that we
should continue to to grapple
with richard in terms of the high points
and the low points in the city's history
where does it comparatively sit today is
it a good time to be a brummie
yeah it is although
um for complicated reasons so
birmingham was not the boom city it was
so in some ways its great economic years
are actually the period 1945 to the
1970s i suppose
it has a really bad time uh in the early
1980s
i think now it's
on the up again although on the up in a
kind of as a more modest city i think
birmingham doesn't quite now fit into
the kind of iconic city mold that it
would have done in the time of joseph
chamberlain and it would have done
perhaps in a slightly different way in
say the 1950s um so i think birmingham's
a much more livable city than it's ever
been before in some ways so that um the
city's finally discovered that
you know the car is not the solution to
everything uh which has transformed
birmingham massively so it brought back
trams which abolished in the 1950s
i think racially it's a much happier
place than it was very nasty racist um
kind of culture around in bits of
birmingham when i was growing up i get
the sense there's much less of that kind
of thing now so i think birmingham's
an a nicer place to live an easier place
to live although
in some ways of course it's become a
more ordinary city so more ordinary city
globally in the sense that you know a
city with about a million inhabitants
you know there are dozens and dozens of
these around the world now um so
birmingham is not the kind of city that
people are looking at around the world
as they were in the time of joseph
chamberlain and of course he attracted
huge attention from americans thinking
about how you run a city from french
people thinking about how you run
politics birmingham doesn't have that
kind of central interest now um but it's
a nice place to be i think
perhaps you know in some ways a more
attractive place to live in than it's
ever been before
adrian what else separates birmingham
from those other cities would you say
our second city is different when it
comes to culture and politics
well i knew i i wonder if i could query
the idea of the second city i know this
is the title of richard's book but i
think andy burnham in manchester would
vigorously say that um the second city
is indeed manchester and one of the
characteristics of birmingham is it's
always been vying for this position of
this of of the second city
um with uh
most notably with with manchester united
that's not a settled position and i
think part of its um
its key characteristics is a sort of
uncertainty or sort of anxiety about
this identity manchester has a very
clear sense of its identity liverpool
has a very clear sense of his identity i
think birmingham has never quite
uh had that or at least not had that
since since the days of
of when joseph chamberlain was was mayor
it's been anxious about its identity
anxious about where it fits in the
hierarchy and the sense that it's looked
down upon
by you know the city just down the road
by by london and the sat and the
southern establishment is a very strong
uh strong thing there that um you know
anxious uncertain about its position in
the world and not willing to project a
common identity now i think that's
beginning to change peaky blinders has
been an enormous benefit to it um but
also having a mayor albeit a mayor of
the of the wider you know west midlands
not just of the city in the form of andy
street who's a very articulate
and proud brummie is giving it much more
of a of a sense of uh self-confidence
which i think
has been lacking and is uh extremely
important well that takes me on to my
last question to both of you richard
andy street is now the mayor of the west
midlands how do you think he's done
well i mean he seems a very articulate
personable person i'm sure he means well
he's not joseph chamberlain and the
culture of joseph chamberlain just isn't
there anymore so
um
adrian talked about confidence now of
course and and he's quite right to say
birmingham does have this uh sense of
insecurity a slightly paradoxical sense
of insecurity because of course learning
actually becomes the second city in
terms of population really after joseph
chamberlain in 1911 when the city
expands a bit um expands quite
dramatically and the period where
birmingham is kind of demographically
and economically important which is
really the 20th century especially the
early part of the 20th century the first
75 years 20th century is also curious
enough to bear where it's least kind of
culturally self-confident
so i think there's a bit of a dichotomy
between economics
and culture
in terms of andy street i think um i
don't actually mention andy street in my
book and i'm sort of getting ready to
write lots of cross letters to reviewers
explaining why i don't mention it
because they're all going to say why
don't you mention it and the reason is a
because he's mayor of the west midlands
not birmingham didn't actually win a
majority of votes in birmingham
because there's a very small turnout in
the mayoral election
about half less than half what you get
in the parliamentary election and of
course in parliamentary terms birmingham
is very heavily represented by labour
mps um i think the tories are
barking up the wrong tree with the idea
that birmingham is their great white
hope for the future because
birmingham is probably a more strongly
labor city now than it ever has been
before
and andy street doesn't have vast powers
so when you look at chamberlain this
extraordinary dynamic
ruthless figure um who transforms
birmingham who builds things who spends
money who buys things um
you know poor old andy street it's very
much kind of an exercise in branding it
seems to me um andy street's a great one
for naming things um and i noticed when
i looked at the most recent map of
birmingham um that uh one of the great
tendencies in birmingham now is that
when an area is problematic you recall
it something which
will sound kind of attractive like
heartland or something like that so it
seems to me that um you know andy
street's a man who
uh is selling images and selling words
but if you look at the previous people
who've dominated birmingham if you look
at chamberlain in the 19th century if
you look
in a perhaps
less
less clear-cut
attractive way at herbert manzoni the
city engineer very powerful figure in
the post-war period these men both left
a very strong physical legacy you could
point to buildings and say
this is there um they're birmingham i
don't think andy street's going to leave
something like that i was very amused
when i was reading about birmingham
trying to think something of something
to say about andy streets birmingham um
that one of the kind of characteristic
initiatives is the creation of something
called a central technology corridor
which sounds very dramatic um which is
going to lead from birmingham university
out into worcestershire and take in the
old long bridge factory and revive the
economy and so on and so forth and i
asked my mother do you know what the
central technology corridor is not a
faintest idea
no one she knows knows what it is which
is strange because they all live in it
so i do think um
andy street is probably not going to
have a very transformative effect on
birmingham
adrian do you think andy schrute has
done well
yeah let me say a few words in favor of
andy street he's obviously uh you know a
relatively small figure compared with
joseph chamberlain but so we all you
know that's that's a giant to compare
people with um but i think um the one of
burma's problems is it's a very sort of
physical city it's not got no natural
center people's uh sense of the place uh
is is local it's their their suburb
rather than the city it doesn't have a
dramatic um set of buildings at the
center in the way that somewhere like
chicago does and i think street has been
quite good in providing uh a center to
the place and he's also been quite good
at um building coalitions of people who
is you know very fragmented ruling class
there he's been very good at bringing
them together getting them all on board
and giving them a sense of sort of
common purpose and identity i think
that's a very uh important political
skill although you know not not a
high-profile one and he's also been very
good in terms of the relations with the
government because with the the you know
the mayors i think that the mayoral
initiative is one of the great
initiatives of the conservatives in
recent years in the sense of britain is
a much much too centralized country and
handing power back to the localities and
to the provinces is a very important
part of what conservatism should be
about and andy street has played a vital
role in that in the sense that he is a
conservative
mayor most of the other high-profile
mayors
particularly with andy burnham are labor
figures and he has been good at selling
the idea of devolution essentially to um
the conservative party
in london uh proving that you can
um as a conservative win um you know a a
mayoral region like that and i think
he's been very influential he's the
person not only that the government goes
to when it wants to talk about you know
the future of devolution but also the
person that people like uh andy burnham
on the the labor side will talk to when
it says how can we get get this message
across to the government so i think both
uh in terms of um building a sense of
identity and a set of alliances in
birmingham and selling this incredibly
important policy of devolution to uh the
conservative party the current
conservative party he's been a pretty
important you know you know national
national figure so not not j not joe
chamberlain but certainly not nothing
adrian and richard thanks for joining me
and finally when people hear about cow
attacks they're often waiting for some
sort of punchline at the end but john
connolly says it isn't so funny to talk
about his recent scrape he joins me now
john in this week's magazine you warned
that cow attacks are no laughing matter
tell us about your recent experience
hell thank you kay um they are a tiny
bit of a laughing matter i should say
but but i'm running a bit by my piece
about how we should take the maybe a
little bit more seriously so um
my incident happened um it was a couple
of years ago my partner and i claire
were walking in devon we'd been out all
day and we arrived at this sort of quite
large field and the only public footpath
in the field was running straight
through into a herd of cows on the other
side who were kind of congregating
around the style that we needed to get
through so
we set off kind of trying to be as
confident as we could we've always been
a bit sort of spooked by animals but you
know being cautious but confident and
then most of the cows were very happy
just kind of ignoring us we didn't hear
anything from them and then this one
sort of slightly larger cow kind of the
moment we came in the field sort of
looked at us and was staring at us quite
intently um but we decided at this stage
probably not not not a point where we
should panic so we carried on and it
then started sort of trotting towards us
and we thought well you know we'll we'll
veer off to the left a bit and sort of
try and curve around them so it realizes
we're not coming for it we're not being
aggressive and it's probably just a bit
curious and we'll leave us be and then
slowly the cows started to pick up pace
and until it's sort of full-on galloping
towards us which at that point we kind
of just froze in our tracks i'm like
okay try not to spook it it's going to
stop when it reaches you and we kind of
kept still and still as it got closer
and closer until it was barely a sort of
a meter away or something like that and
it was it felt like right on top of us
and
it kind of didn't look like it was
stopping at that point so i kind of
completely panicked and shouted run at
the top of my voice
um
at that point the cow stopped read up on
its back legs and and kind of went for
me basically we both sprinted off in
slightly different ways
it went for me it was it was awful and
after was my partner could see it and
she was saying it was it was gaining on
me basically it was right on my back um
and she thought i was gonna be trampled
to death so um yeah we managed to get it
was sort of an l-shaped field we managed
to go around the corner and it kind of
eased off then and uh managed to escape
through a hedge and
yeah afterwards we kind of
it was it was a completely ridiculous
sort of situation but then but quite
soon after we were like well we're
actually quite traumatized by this we
were quite shaken up and we took like
you know at least a couple of days to
sort of calm down and like okay it's all
fine it's all gonna be okay so oh it's
so scary john there's nothing funny
about that you've kind of already
answered my second question which was
how close you thought you were to being
trampled by a killer cow and it sounds
like you were pretty darn close yeah i
mean i i kind of looked up afterwards i
was like you know is it was it just
those were being a bunch of horses and
and then you kind of come across these
reports of quite serious incidents where
people are sort of battered by cows they
come away with serious injuries
um
the reason i did the p-section was
reminded of it was that that last week a
woman in lancashire
uh was out walking i think she was with
a group of people and they kind of the
cows surrounded her
didn't let her go and then were
head-butting her and she had i think 15
broken ribs she tried to walk and her
foot just gave way i think she'd got a
shattered ankle so she had to like crawl
out of this field on her hands uh and
knees and and sort of pull herself over
a wall uh before mountain rescue could
arrive so it kind of underlined to me
that yeah it is these things can be
quite serious and yeah that's the
problem
yeah terrifying can you give us a bit of
perspective having written up this piece
and looked at some of the statistics
around it how worried should people be
about cow attacks what do the figures
say is this a frequent occurrence um i
mean i wouldn't be worried if you're
like in your own home uh
right sure sure
context matters
it's basically more common than you
think so i mean not that many people are
killed by cows every year i think it's
sort of around four or five and quite a
few of those will be people who work on
farms but you know there are usually one
or two walkers um
last year it was particularly high
because i think a lot of people were out
in the countryside during lockdown
um but the point that so i talked a bit
to a campaign group which was set up a
few years ago um called killer cows and
they um they collect sort of uh
people's stories and that kind of thing
and and they kind of point out that
whilst they're sort of the worst most
tragic incidents do get recorded in
terms of uh deaths and occasionally the
most serious injuries in the papers we
kind of don't really have a huge idea of
how many
near misses how many sort of minor
injuries and and quite nasty scares
happen and and i suspect it's a lot more
frequent basically
well since you're you're scraped with
the killer cow have you done any
research as to how walkers can stay safe
especially if they're quite close to
these herds yeah i mean this is a really
interesting thing so um
uh one thing that does seem to be the
case is that
uh people with dogs do are the ones who
tend to be more seriously hurt but
equally um there's there's a decent
theory that around half of the sort of
attacks happen without dogs anyway um an
obvious one is to avoid cows with calves
um
but equally i think i think it can just
happen at the blue i think a common
misconception as well apparently is that
that cows see red and go after you for
that um that's that's not the case
apparently they don't really see red
very well um though i have so i want to
have been told which apparently works is
that you shouldn't carry sort of carrier
bags when you're going through a field
with cows because they can often
mistake you for someone carrying food
and are more likely to come over but
there is a bit of there is a bit of
blind look to it um to be honest and i
think you can just be a bit unlucky well
i'm really glad you were on the lucky
side
you say in your article that most people
will listen to a story about a cow
attack and wait for the punch line but
most people who've been in this
experience don't have a punch line to
give because they don't actually find it
all that funny
yeah and it's kind of mixed like so
as i was saying like you do sort of
acknowledge that you're in a ridiculous
situation when you've been attacked by a
cow but then
um but yeah and it is a sort of strange
thing as they if you are a bit
traumatized by if you are a bit upset i
mean maybe trauma is too long but i
think too strong but something close to
it at least you kind of are looking for
a bit more sympathy and you think if if
any animal of that size had chased
someone i mean uh cows weigh a similar
amount to black bears for example um i'd
rather be chased by a cow than a bear i
should've had but the point
but we don't want either situation right
this doesn't have to be the trade-off no
but yeah you don't tend to get uh tend
to get tons of sympathy to be honest i
think people do think it is a bit funny
and um
the woman i was talking to at the killer
cows were saying that people have had
really horrendous injuries like actual
hospitalizations and things are still
met with a lot of these jokes about you
know oh you should move out the way why
didn't you understand all that kind of
stuff um
yeah so i
think it is sort of we can sort of see a
bit of the humor in it but i think yeah
it should be taken a tad more seriously
and have a bit of empathy for those
who've had a desperate run-in with a cow
i think well i certainly will now having
listened to your experience
my last question john is since your
recent encounter with the cow will you
be thinking twice before you go on
another rambling through the countryside
um we have since to be honest um
it's it's it spooked us a bit um we do
try and go on walks i um still but i
tend to try and pick out ones which are
a bit more sort of mountainous and hilly
because i think there'll be fewer cows
uh they're high healthy
if we come across cows
in a field we do always try and find
like another field we can sort of pass
through um that might annoy some if
there are any farmers listening because
your men stick to the right of way but
um it's kind of it's motivated by fear
rather than malice
but it's not always but it's not always
possible to avoid cows in the
countryside and i don't think it ever
will be so uh yeah it's it's a difficult
one to get around and it's obviously a
balance because i know farmers have very
difficult times and they probably hear
all this and they think well we do
enough we've got enough pressures on
without having to worry about walkers
you know potentially being hurt by a cow
but um as of all these things it's a bit
of a balance and yeah that's how it's
affected us anyway it's all about those
calculated risks john thanks for joining
spectator tv
thank you very much
and that's it for this week remember if
you enjoy what we do here at the
spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content join
today and you'll pay just one pound a
week for unlimited online and app access
in your first year to subscribe today go
to spectator dot co dot uk forward slash
tv offer
and don't forget to subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week on the week in 60
minutes
[Music]
you